the zombie makeup they get was such a
good job with you but it must take a
long time to make you up as a zombie it
takes about an hour and 45 minutes in
the morning and then about 45 minutes to
take it off at the end of the day but
the thing is it's I have to do the full
makeup process to get it on but it's
quite easy and tempting to just half-ass
it when you take it off yeah so I have
had on a couple of occasions like still
had my wig cap on and these sunken sort
of black eyes and bits of zombie makeup
and I've stopped at supermarkets and
things on the way home and not thought
about it though and I remember walking
through a supermarket once where I'm
sure they'll have like a wanted sign for
me now but it was me walking throughout
and the phone just goodness knows who
but saying like well this brain that I
ate today you know it was a sociopathic
brain and it's a little bit difficult to
play that and just this whole thing look
why your jaw is falling I was falling
off and people did they do they I did
Jambi makeup for I yeah walking dead
they caked it on and I was almost
disappointed at how I still looked so
much like my I think we have a photo of
it I still look so much you know what
we'd love I mean I might be speaking out
of turn but if you came in cameoed on
iZombie I think you would be the only
person who needs to get a spray tan to
look like I am one of those guys you can
see my veins coming beautiful this is me
right now we're 30 layers of makeup on
we tan you up a bit we ten you do that
please